passat passat psp psp service sg zh und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von diversity zwei meiner absoluten
lieblings map for prime time und wir
befinden uns hier im moment damit letzte
folge bei ghom beendet falls er die
verpasst hat schott da auf jeden fall
nochmal nach da wir uns diesen pinken
blöcke geholt und es war sehr
unterhaltsam
ohne heutige zweite der waren glaube ich
zu wissen zutaten zu czempik erfahren
ich würde sagen wir machen heute mal
roth basel
kassel louis dupont du okay das ist
glaube ich sehr an sich das ist bei die
einst war das richtig hart es war echt
es war echt nicht ohne
ja und da muss unsere grauen zellen
anstrengen aber schaffen bin ich ich sag
jetzt schon mal vorweg ok ja genau so
einer scheiße war das auch damals
schaffen bin ich ja noch jens 7
aber egal was mal okay das sieht gar
nichts mehr so wir machen mal bestellen
sie mich ja darauf die mitte hier no
es war nämlich dann nämlich so aus wie
beim ersten mal
ok ok kommend ich verstehe nicht denn
wir sind gerade ihr habt mir nicht durch
überall nicht
hier geht das licht immer an also licht
geht an bis sich alle lichter erstmal an
machen vielleicht ein paar andere aus
andere aus dass natürlich die dann
müsste man natürlich dann gucken was
gibt vivo aus und was gibt wo an
meinst du das kann die sache sein dass
man diese systematik kennen muss
zu recht wir haben schon viele davon an
diesem tag die sache ist wenn du 1
entweder also wenn du auf den schalter
da geht es dann geht das direkt oben
drüber entweder aus und alle alle drei
außenrum an
oder du machst oder verändern sich dann
auch okay der trick ist dann vielleicht
erst mal alle auszumachen
weißt du wie course wenn er everything
is off than you can turn mit das ist der
richtige weg dann also wenn ja dann mach
dann mach ich doch hier dem wieder an
oder nicht dann euch doch da den auch
wieder an
wir sind jetzt hier fast alles aussehen
der ecke alles an irgendwie gerade ja
obwohl ich als ausmacht eigentlich für
alles außer dass an machen sollen was
denn jetzt
das ist darf man das bin ich muss das
mal ganz kurz
ist da nicht hatcher will pillars kommen
wieder hinter ihr ein kind mikrochips
oder hat seine buch mit dem titel ich
mache mal hinter jedoch auch hier nicht
gefunden
wir können es einfach mal aus der masse
eine ecke heraus bewegen wir ihnen alle
aus kommen alle aus jetzt haben wir noch
diesen ihr ein mann eben noch 123 dann
sind nur noch drei tage später
ich kann aber versuchen hin zu machen
irgendwie bei ihrer mal höher
pro jahr was passiert michael 17 cross
the ceiling okay also auch die die
draußen sind alles klar machen wir das
so wurde
da kann nicht passten
das waren drei wochen später folgen die
hitze einfach so sinnlos und trivial ist
sie noch ausgehen
wir haben noch die ganzen hinter danach
mal eben kurz aber ich glaube nicht dass
finden
silber ist dass wir hier zu einem puzzle
simple fein okay okay er almost all vor
uns müssen wir den letzten finden der
letzte ist an der htwg und vor allem das
ist richtig asozial die map alter wenn
er mit ihr stehen richtig gemein was
passiert ist
also pps also klasse platz also psps
also klasse pass apps apps apps apps
apps apps apps
da brauchte ich so etwas auf
zusammenlegen
ich glaube das ist ungefähr die mitte so
kann das sieht ein bisschen nach der
mitte aus haben wir einmal die ecke
teile schon gefunden glaube ich dass ein
abteil
was haben wir das schwierig zu erkennen
hier ist ein scale and one theme
das könnte ich mir wieder weg hast du
noch teile
nein gar keine echte wissen italien
gut ich beziehe so ein komisches teil
des ew es ist falsch dass sein dass
passten aber das proben passt glaube ich
grad passt auch eigentlich so passt
passt dass hier das passt dass das ist
also scheint mir im vergleich haben
machbar
ja das kann relativ viel in dem alle
teilnehmen die leiste rein aber das
passt irgendwie auch nicht so
ja ja passen meiner meinung nach nicht
so zusammen die was passt nicht so zu
sagen ja diese ecken diesen komisch
gesetzt wie ich finde die ecken
so eine schlecht ausgeleuchtet das passt
aber anhand das licht das ganze dann
irgendwie sowas fallen für falsch gerade
einzel das ist richtig so werde das meer
der stimmt nicht ganz denn hier oben
oder unten so im ernstfall steht die
passen auch an sich oder ich finde passt
das zu denn der mitte unter der mann ist
eben komisch aus welcher der ja
also nicht und ich will einfach nach
links nicht so anders irgendwie drehen
ok
vorteile haben wir dennoch ich kann mir
gar nicht mal die cassandra steen
hierfür müsst ihr noch irgend so ein
stück haben irgendwas was ich hier habe
ich geld aber das ist vollkommen falsch
da oben links
alles passt nicht oben links toleranz
stück ich mir noch also dass linken rand
hat hast du hast das hier vielleicht
herr wir haben keine sachen ja doch das
passt oder um rein so das ist gut
jetzt wollen auch für den rechten rand
irgendwas hast du noch irgendwas geiles
an andere andere sachen und und
austauschen oder 16 aber guck mal so
passt das ungefähr vom verlauf her oder
annäherung aber die ecke da oben die ist
halt falsch
die ecke ist kacke die ecke selbst die
etwa falscher um die männer ein die sich
hierbei um die ecke ist also mit somit
zum orangenen dingen und hast du noch
teile und du kannst ja immer nach den
belichtungs verhältnissen gehen sie
jetzt auf den rahmen rausgeschlagen das
natürlich schlecht vielleicht die
musterprofi bis nach demnach muss bis
nach dem nicht gehen
komisch ist aber auch schwarz hier drei
leute gerade in meinem aufnahmeraum sg
für euch
ja das sieht gut aus
ja du bist ein bisschen ja so ein
bisschen albern aber noch ein stück
das würde ich da oben genommen aber
wisse das nicht dahin haben wir schon
wie das aussehen die beiden tauschen
okay ein anderer seite das ist die
andere seite die fackel
naja aber die mitte so ich glaube du
hast noch ein stück ich habe kein rand
stück ab 3
hier ist doch gar nicht schlecht aus der
irgendwie da da da da so ja fast alles
klar jetzt komme jetzt haben den rahmen
so weidner rahmen ist soweit richtig
aber das würde vielleicht muss das da
unten hin
ja sicher nicht so muss das tier noch
zehn dinge irgendwie aber das sieht auch
irgendwie nicht so richtig mache
malereien einfach so mit macken habe ich
ein stück okay als wir den anderen
stücken du bist noch ein stück ich habe
ein stück passt das hierhin vom verlauf
her auf jeden fall ja
das ist ein bisschen komisch aussehen
die schattierung ihr passt nicht ganz
ja nicht so ganz ist das passiert
natürlich nicht mal hier unten ist ein
roter rand das muss so rein und das muss
so rein vielleicht und dass da jetzt
da muss man rechnen müssen war dann aber
das sieht komisch aus maintal die ecke
die es gibt